en cada
una de estas imágenes lamentablemente
cada vez son más frecuentes los cuerpos
sin vida de muchos migrantes algunos de
ellos muy jóvenes están siendo
enterrados en cementerios musulmanes
ubicados en las cercanías de la frontera
polaco bielorrusa una consecuencia de la
crisis migratoria en la región
estas personas dejaron sus hogares sus
países sus tierras de origen
por turismo para ver países hermosos
sino porque querían encontrar una vida
mejor por sobre todas las islas
seychelles pero podrán llegar a esa vida
mejor el obstáculo más reciente es el
invierno que se avecina y amenaza su
estadía en los campamentos además del
tránsito a través de los bosques que
cruzan clandestinamente de polonia a
alemania país que rechazó habilitar un
corredor humanitario muchos migrantes
debido a las dificultades han tomado la
iniciativa de volver a su país
repatriados por el gobierno de belarús
mientras tanto en polonia advierten una
mejoría migratoria o rossi
de migrantes a belarús es diferente es
menor al pico de arribos de hace un mes
o de hace tres semanas
esto es importante porque es el primer
paso para mitigar la crisis desatada por
belarús
pese a los esfuerzos al menos 174
intentos de cruce de frontera hacia
polonia se registraron en las últimas 24
horas de acuerdo con lo informado por la
guardia de fronteras de ese país